the winner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right after mailings crowning moment et
joined her with coach John Legend
backstage I've been trying to take this
whole process one step at a time because
there was so much unknown all I know is
that I am gonna work very hard I'm ready
to hit the ground running so whatever it
is I'm ready for it and I want to
release music and I want to tour and I
know that that's in the cards how it's
gonna play out I'm not sure but I'm okay
with that too I'm ready to to kind of go
with the flow I just can't believe she
was like just singing in small bars in
New York like very recently with that
voice I mean she needs to be heard by a
lot more people the season 16 finale of
The Voice was star-studded with
performances by some of the biggest
names in music like Taylor Swift who
performed her hit single me with Brendon
Urie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the Jonas Brothers kept the colorful
theme going singing their track cool
[Music]
and the party kept bumping with BTS who
brought down the house with their big
energy and slick moves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]